i'm julia uh i am quietly online under
the
twitter handle big commitment and i
wrote a song about
javascript and javascript interpreters
which i will play for you shortly
but first a little background in context
so
the inspiration for all of this was what
if i made a cover of
bang bang my baby shot me down but made
it about the bang bang operator in
javascript instead
so why um
a few reasons one i am committed to the
full realization
of terrible puns and secondly
i was curious um firstly
just like okay if i made this terrible
pun song what would that even sound like
what would the lyrics be
who the characters in this view and
secondly
um it just got me thinking like how does
a bank then really work
in javascript like i have some idea
probably evaluate but
really like what's going on um if i have
this expression
like let some cool equal bang bang some
variable
i was really interested in digging into
like what
what is this moment that like this final
bang gets applied
like it's i don't know it just sounded
like dramatic and i wanted to
explore that more so
um yeah let's just review what a bang
bang
is so um it's just two
logical not operators together so
if you have a classic boolean true apply
one bang you false another bank true
um but it's a little more interesting in
javascript land because you can apply
this to
anything such as numbers
some numbers will typically return true
except for
zero which returns false um
strings shout out to shark
um so oh except the empty string
returns false um and even objects
so um
a little one here um but this is a part
that
kind of like threw me because i was
expecting this to return false but
actually returns
true and actually similarly with lists
and empty lists will return
true as well so it seems that like most
of the time
like it's true but sometimes most times
false but then sometimes it's true
so what's that about um
so it turns out that like a bang bang
will return uh
true if the input is truthy and
false if it is falsy and maybe you've
just heard the terms truthy and falsey
for the first time certain
are like did you just make that up um
and
no it's a real thing someone else made
it up i'm just
the messenger so um
it's not too bad though uh so how we
think about it is that there are only a
set amount of
falsely values there's eight in total
so there are the original false three
different flavors of zero
the empty string null undefined and not
a number
and anything else will be considered
truthy
so now that we know a little bit about
what abandoning is how does a bang bang
work how does it get evaluated
interpreted
um so it turns out that computers are
complicated
uh browsers are complicated javascript
is
strange but uh to answer this a little
bit
um so like your browser
has a javascript engine and the
javascript engine will run that
javascript
and every engine is a little bit
different but
um more or less they'll like parse
interpret the file
and run and in va's case have this
little aside it's like
it'll try to optimize it and then like
there's this floor trial that's like
sometimes it like optimizes too much and
it has to like de-optimize
and then like yeah it's a wild world
right there
um but uh the song will cover this
a bit more as well um and
yeah so and uh v8 is the javascript
engine that chrome uses and i chose to
focus on that because it's open source i
can
attempt to dig through the code and
understand what's going on
so um the song will be coming out
shortly so yeah i was like
okay what what's the song gonna be about
um and so taking all this and like
digging through the code
i decided to focus on okay what if i am
a javascript object
how do i travel through this engine
pipeline
through this parser and interpreter and
how do i get evaluated as
so that's kind of what the song is about
and i think the video will be ready to
roll
[Music]
i was lying so
[Music]
then
[Music]
and
[Music]
my
[Music]
so is
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
[Music]
what
[Music]
then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
shiny
once they saw i was
they didn't care what was inside me
they just saw me as true
[Music]
realizations
[Music]
my
you